[Musique]
le plus délicat pour le pilote et
caraïbes reste de poser son avion en
douceur
sur certaines pistes c'est un
atterrissage qui est délicat qui compte
parmi les plus difficiles mais quand on
[Applaudissements]
l'est on respecte bien il faut de
l'expérience pour pouvoir atterrir sur
ces pistes originales
les pilotes doivent posséder des
qualifications spécial ça pas été simple
mais l'aviation civile a joué le jeu en
place on terrains à usage restreint et
on a su et ils sont tous les pilotes à
une qualification de terrain qui est
encore d'actualité
actuellement si la qualification limite
les risques
elle ne pourra jamais les éliminer
totalement mais des accidents il peut y
en avoir partout et pas forcément là où
on s'y attend
[Musique]
les instruments de navigation aérienne
ont beaucoup évolué ils sont aujourd'hui
d'importants facteurs de sécurité à
l'époque des pionniers il n'existait pas
ça s'appelait à piloter aux fesses c'est
au nez parce qu'on avait comme aide à la
navigation qu'une boussole est
évidemment il s'est beaucoup plus facile
aujourd'hui qu'à l'époque beaucoup plus
facile nous maintenant on est quand même
des privilégiés parce que le matériel a
beaucoup évolué comme dans tous les
domaines alors que les véritables
pionniers comme un vrai mi2n où je
faisais dort en moi c'était vraiment un
autre monde
on voulait sans radio laisse en plan de
vol sans savoir sans connaître la météo
on n'avait aucune communication avec qui
vraiment on en faisait une estimation
d'après la vitesse d'après le vent
pendant un cap approximatif pour pencher
pour la dérive emportée puy-en-velay
brière blocage roman dense et jamais
perdu aujourd'hui l'ombre des pionniers
plane toujours sur les caraïbes
car on rend hommage à leurs efforts josé
dormoy a longtemps habité l'île de
saint-eustache dans la petite aérogare
élit sa veuve a contribué à une petite
exposition à la mémoire des pionniers de
l'aviation
le but que l'on se souvienne des
exploits de ces aviateurs de légende et
que l'on sache combien ils ont contribué
au développement des îles
[Musique]
à saint martin la poste hollandaise a
édité une série de timbres à l'effigié
de ses grand aviateur
nous
[Musique]